the joggin experience do you know of
there's a very famous painting that
shows what appears to be men in crafts
flying through the sky in the background
of an ancient painting do you know I'm
talking about I do I actually have a
page one of the first pages ever put on
my website is like a bunch of these
because throughout history there are
these indications of ships of crap but
you know what the one I'm talking about
it's like and yes that that's the shape
of it it's also like a plate turned on
its side and then there's a person
inside of it yeah yeah man it's it's
flying through in that same yeah that's
it yeah like look how it it's flying but
you know the thing is is it everybody
can say are the one above that's pretty
cool because that was a hidden thing
I've studied that one where it says
discovery 15th century above the her
left shoulder
there is an object and if you really
zoom in look at the dude staring up at
it as a painter my wife is a painter
everything is intentional
where's the ground yeah right over there
it's pretty cool looking up so I think
that's 15th century it said so that the
problem with this Joe is it go to the
original one the one that we just looked
at Jamie the one right before that yeah
so you get a big picture yeah that is so
strange like here you got Christ being
crucified and then above him UFOs like
is that supposed to be aliens or is that
supposed to be angels like so what is
that supposed to be in these things that
they have it's severe it's real similar
to what we're talking about here that's
the argument of miracle Fatima let's say
I'm again this is so speculative we have
a witness here a pilot but when you see
something like the miracle of Fatima if
you look at the miracle of Fatima God
that's that one that was you know
considered a real miracle by the church
and the three kids we're getting
messages I'll get this all wrong but for
like months that they're gonna be
visited and to bring people and bigger
and bigger groups gathered to where
there was over a hundred thousand people
years of and I just haven't seen 1917 so
you know dozens of thousands if not
hundreds but dozens for sure see an
event a mass
of something that happened we're talking
people that were religious people that
weren't religious you know doctors at
the desk on a real image there's a gym
now ones doctor a little bit so you
could see like they're all looking at
something but that's not real yeah
that's the but that's the crowd right
the crowd is real is that right so
here's the thing people come out
something happened that was so intense
some people thought it was religious
that it was a visitation but other
people saw it as technological like
something descended you know look into
I'm just saying art pictures like
paintings we're talking about men you
can interpret them all day I can't hold
on to that I can't hold on to an
eyewitness with other eyewitnesses with
radar systems and with video we're in a
different era now we don't have to paint
it man we get to see it it's fascinating
that it is fascinating but it's way more
fascinating when someone like you talks
about it versus some [ __ ] random kook
you know that's that's what makes me
incredibly interested is the just your
credibility in the fact that this is not
you know I'm a history of seeing wacky
[ __ ] that other people don't see no just
this once and but it's the on video and
that there's other ones as well this
it's really strange and I've seen people
try to explain it away
and what I don't like about when they
explained it away or attempt to explain
it away is that they're trying really
hard they're not going who knows what
this [ __ ] thing is they're not
looking at it like cleanly they're
looking at it like a quote-unquote
skeptic I don't like the idea of being a
skeptic not that I don't think you
should be skeptical of certain things
I'd certainly think you should be but
there's a lot of people that brand
themselves as skeptics and I think it's
a lazy way to look at things I really do
because I think you're just looking for
the holes in things without looking at
it objectively if you wanted to be a
scientist if you wanted to be someone
who is a fan of science then you have to
look at it as a thing like look at this
information and let's study this without
any bias any preconceived notions I
don't think they're doing that they're
looking at it they're trying to find a
way where they can justify that it's
fake and they're they're just doing all
sorts of mental gymnastics to try to
make it fake
that video that you show where that
thing slips off to the left and takes
off at incredible rates of speed that
alone should freak people the [ __ ] out
yeah well I think because people confuse
all the time like we took the video no
it was another crew that took the video
we we watched it for five minutes with
our eyeballs and there was four of us
and we all have the same story we all
saw the same stuff we all came back and
looked at each other and scratched her
head and said WTF you know I mean
serious what was that
[Applause]